في الساحه الاوكرانيه امدادات عسكريه لا
تتوقف اسلحه تقليديه واخرى تفرض نفسها
عسكريا
تقول صحيفه ان تغييرات تجتاح الصناعات
الدفاعيه وصراعا يهز شركات الاسلحه
التقليديه العملاقه
شركات الاسلحه الكبرى تواجه تحديات من
وافدين جدد شركات ناشئه تتقدم بسرعه وتسهم
بتغييرات اوسعه في تجارات الاسلحه الصحيفه
استعرضت بعض ابرز الاسلحه التي تحتل مكانه
في الساحه الاوكرانيه الاقمار الصناعيه
المستعاره تعمل بالطاقه الشمسيه طويله
التحمل تستخدم للمراقبه الطائرات بدون
طيار السلاح الذي اثبت فعاليته قبل الحرب
في اوكرانيا حتى المسيرات الانتحاريه او
المتسكعه طائره صغيره الحجم مذخره
العربه المسيره تؤدي مهام متعدده
كالاستطلاع والقتال وازاله الالغام واجلاء
الضحايا توفر تلك الاسلحه ميزه تفتقر لها
التقليديه كخفتها ومرونه توريدها اضافه
الى الفعاليات العسكريه المعتمده على
معلومات اجهزه الاستشعار ومعالجه البيانات
والحوسبه منتجات عسكريه يرى خبراء انها
تحقق رغبه المشترين في الحصول على
تكنولوجيا افضل ومتطوره باسعار معقوله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات